so you're riding in an early prototype
of the observer to e top speeds 90 miles
per hour we're not in production yet
will go into production in the fourth
quarter this year this little guy is
telling us the range that we can drive
one this is a to a range and that's the
one way range a single charge will last
hundred miles with two people in it all
of the accessories going and with a with
a duty cycle mostly of running 70 miles
per hour down the freeway the exterior
shape is very close the interior is
still being refined and we're making
more improvements to the interior the
vehicle as we as we go so this is
actually connected with gsm network so
you can actually dump your google
calendar directly through here
you know you're tracking want to go the
best buy and it'll actually plan your
route for you
you